don't use CH GPT Fair College admissions
essay try this instead meet kigo your AI
powered College adviser from KH Academy
like an admissions expert Kingo will
walk you through questions to brainstorm
and narrow essay ideas that capture your
unique story you'll work through the
five keys to a strong personal statement
a hook conflict transformation lesson
learned and the lasting impact on you
and your goals with a strong topic and
plan ready you'll write your first draft
Kiko is there to give feedback to
improve your writing as you go with K
Migo's expert review you'll not only
make your deadlines but submit an essay
which showcases everything you have to
be proud of click the link in the
description to get started writing with
kigo and boost your shot at getting into
your dream school good luck